foreign
tis I your fearful host
of the into the impossible podcast
Ing live
Friday January 6th
2023 still writing 2022 on my checks and
my paychecks you have to sign the front
and the back
of your paychecks don't forget
and I thought it would be a lot of fun
to answer some questions and also to
celebrate the fact that we have 80
000 subscribers on this channel now on
YouTube alone another 50 000 on audio
and I really want to thank you all for
such incredible support and love and and
generosity with your thumbs and your
comments and all the cool stuff that you
guys are doing
and I thought it'd be fun to uh take
some
take some maybe some live comments and
questions and just have a good time
before the sun goes down and I turn into
a pumpkin and just a few uh more minutes
about an hour we'll try to do this for
an hour
uh and it's really gratifying to see the
growth of the community and all the
feedback
tripling and doubling faster than a than
a virus and it's r factor and it's
hopefully a positive mind virus
transmitting to you all and sharing with
you all and I learned a tremendous
amount from my listeners and guests
obviously I just recorded in uh two
episodes in the last two days one with
uh brilliant young postdoc in the UK in
the US Oliver Phil Cox who is part of a
team that's claimed detection of very
very interesting
um phenomenon called Cosmic polarization
sorry called Cosmic parity violation
which in the words of Mark kaminkowski
one of the most eminent scientists alive
and a friend and a mentor could lead to
a Nobel Prize for uh Dr Phil Cox and
you'll see that soon and I already have
a Nobel Prize that I'm waiting to give
him that I stole from my friend Barry
barish who I'm doing a in-person
interview with in about two weeks at his
home new home home institution of the
University of California so we're
colleagues he is at UC Riverside
and I'm going up there to give a
colloquium and he will be there and he
and I will do an episode about uh about
his life story and kind of follow up on
the three or four conversations we've
had I've interviewed him and he
interviewed me once on the podcast as
well and that was a lot of fun of course
he wrote the forward to my latest book
called think like a Nobel Prize winner
and you can read all about that in that
book and I also want to encourage folks
to subscribe to my mailing list it's
there brianking.com list
if you're in the US you have a chance to
win real space Schmutz so meteorites I
keep them somewhere around here in my in
my laboratory setting let's see I'm at a
loss for them right now oh here's one
here's some so if you want some we've
got some
if you're in the US
uh and it's just been tremendous wow T
car my my my brother from another mother
uh the man the myth the legend thank you
for a hundred dollar
Super Chat that it's just insane and so
generous of you folks joining us from
London from Laos from all around the
world oh my God it's so cool I never
thought about this would be a
possibility obviously when I was a kid
but even a couple of years ago and this
channel is only two years old
and we've had incredible uh growth and
uh really the growth allows me to do uh
to do a tremendous amount more and gives
me the energy to to Really up my game
and I built out a studio or in the
process of building a studio here in the
laboratory at Keating Labs UC San Diego
and uh we got all sorts of cool stuff
coming for you this year
but you know when somebody wishes you a
happy new year and it's you know
February 3rd you kind of think that
they're an idiot uh and I wanted to make
sure that I released my favorite
um kind of content top hits from
astronomy and physics as soon as
possible uh into the new year and
ideally that would have been on December
31st before the new year but I got laid
up with some kind of illness I don't
think it was covered but I'm feeling
better and things are going well and I
did end up doing a Twitter space in
which
friend of the show Eric Weinstein joined
and that was great so you can find that
I made a video from it and it's on the
channel uh and just one more reminder
just to please uh check out the video
that reads today which not surprisingly
confirm the work of uh an up-and-coming
physicist I think I have them around
here somewhere
um in bobblehead form this is Galileo I
got Galileo here uh and that's Albert
Einstein whose gravity remains uh
unified with the Notions of quantum
mechanics and some of that's due to the
work of the famous ice cube experiment
uh which is located at the South Pole
where I've spent many a day freezing my
took us off as they say
and I love it down there and he leads
France housing leads the Ice Cube
experiment an interview with him which
is really one of my favorites of 2022
um and he's just such a generous uh
honest vulnerable deep individual uh new
George lemitra and we talked about that
talked about pedagogy how to be a mentor
how to be a teacher how to be a
scientific leader we almost uh you know
ran out of time recording space he has
so much wisdom to share so today's video
is about Ice Cube's actual discovery
which led to me inviting him on the
podcast and I actually had him as a
professor a long long time ago
Michael Dan how are you shabbat shalom
uh and I wanted to kind of you know riff
off that with a deep dive into the
experimental details of Ice Cube and
what allowed them to make this
announcement back in October in nature
magazine about a confirmation that
Einstein was right that the laws of um
what are called Lorenzen variants are
respected throughout the universe so
that was a really fun discussion I had
with him but the video is about the
actual ins and outs of the detector and
how it works and how they actually did
constrain lorentz and variants violation
and what we can do about that going
forward
so that we can really learn If gravity
and quantum mechanics are actually
unified or if they're not there's no law
that says they have to be Unified
and a lot of people kind of act in
physics as if it does have to be unified
but there's really no mandate as I say
letter from God that says we have to do
that and uh when I discuss this you know
phenomena that is very difficult as a
guest that I haven't gotten yet he did
promise to come on Nema or Connie Hamed
has promised me to come on I was
supposed to be with him this week in
Glasgow oh no in Edinburgh and Borough
enber not Edinburgh as I said by
accident when I talked to the great Neil
Turok Neil invited me to a conference
that's going on this week up there in
Edinburgh
and I couldn't make it because I'm going
on a super secret mission uh in the next
week and a half and it would have
required me to go and just do some crazy
stuff that I was unwilling to do given
family demands but anyway well stay
tuned for more information about that
today is all about
the top hits of 2022 and what you guys
think about it and uh whether or not you
agree with some of the selections that I
chose and what we can look forward to in
2023
and I did post a poll on my YouTube
channel Dr Brian Keating where you're
watching right now and it got over 1400
1500 votes
and I was kind of reluctant to put down
what I knew would be the greatest hit of
all of 2022 in the world of astronomy
which was jwst so I put down five
different well I put down four real
options nuclear fusion yielding net
positive energy output which we talked
about with professor Charles seif in
late December
the Wormhole that was allegedly created
in a quantum computer
uh the fact that the phosphine claims
which is a biomarker that Venus was said
to have had about three years ago I had
an episode with Sarah Seeger and other
collaborators from MIT and her group and
other groups that claimed they had
detected this this molecule which looks
a lot like ammonia except instead of
having instead of having nitrogen it has
phosphorus so it's ph3 for you playing
at home instead of NH3
and that was said to be not only uh
really consistent with a biological
origin but really consistent with that
life form existing in the Clouds of
Venus where we're used to thinking about
only carbon dioxide and uh future
hellscape that may await us on Earth if
we don't take heed to Tim Palmer who's
past guest on the show and his advice to
create a cern-like Organization for
combating climate change so look at that
episode so uh there was that option that
got the least vote six percent of you
thought that was a big news that we
ruled out in a a discovery that had been
claimed several years ago to much
fanfare and actually that reminds me to
plug a future video now I'm going to do
another solo episode
when I hit 90 000 maybe I don't know uh
we'll see uh when I do it but that's
what I call the academic media hype
complex kind of like the military
industrial complex that Eisenhower
warned us against but in this case it's
the super cycle that occurs when
scientists and the media uh kind of form
a flywheel which then creates this
Unstoppable uh Juggernaut leading
through to perhaps un retractable claims
and uh makes it extremely difficult high
pressure on scientists raises tons of
ethical issues that we are wholly
unqualified to address in most cases let
me speak for myself and I want to use
some of my uh com you know kind of
personal experience with these uh
phenomena including my bicep experience
I wrote about in my book losing the
Nobel Prize
and I also want to include some other
things that have come out namely the
nuclear fusion issue the Wormhole claim
and the phosphine retraction and what
these do to not only to the Public's
perception of science but also to
scientists themselves in kind of the
sociology of science but today we won't
talk so look for that video the academic
media hype complex
uh and that'll be a fun video to do and
I hope to uh to present it in the not
too distant future but if you want to
help the Channel please yeah do things
like you guys are doing leave thumbs up
leave comments and but most of all
really encourage your friends and family
people ask how to how to help me I love
I love money no no I don't love money's
great it's great to get money big super
chats in there but really I'm trying to
expand a mission and the money will help
me do that because I have to pay
producers and technicians and so forth
to edit this and uh it's really so
gratifying that you guys tune in people
watch thousands you know I look at these
huge channels that have way more video
view way more subscribers by factor of
10. and you guys are more loyal and
you're watching these videos longer and
uh and I'm always as I said I'm trying
to up my game uh and so if you like what
I'm doing you can do a couple things one
first thing is is really encourage
people to subscribe to the channel but
also subscribe to the newsletter I send
out juicy little tidbits what I'm
thinking about
and uh that's something that YouTube
can't really squelch I've had a bunch of
videos lately including the climate uh
police uh putting a stamp of disapproval
in some ways on my video with Charles
seif so we talked about nuclear fusion
and how the nuclear fusion you know may
be hype as well and that video which is
about solving climate CR you know
catastrophes all right if we have a um a
you know kind of unlimited energy source
we could scrub the atmosphere of every
single carbon dioxide atom that we have
we're just limited by energy so that was
a positive thing that the human
Ingenuity can present a solution to
climate change and yet the gods of
YouTube
sort of suppress it they put a warning
label on it linked to un I don't know
why to the U.N I was hoping they'd link
it to Charles Schwab or the world
economic Forum but they didn't
um but nevertheless we keep going I had
a very wonderful conversation as you
know with Jay about acharya one of his
most revealing and deep interviews with
you know um the only faculty member
that's really runs a podcast like this
and has reached out to him that was
slapped with a covid-19 Wikipedia you
know warning and you know be careful and
demonetized so again money is wonderful
I can't thank you guys enough uh for
that that is that is you know such a
such a a complete blessing
um but it'll be great to really grow the
audience as they say a lot of things
will will happen if we get bigger we can
certainly get
even more kind of phenomenal deep Dives
and guests and and I know I also I'm not
afraid to take on controversial topics
and some of those will require your
patience and your support
um there's a very very good possibility
that Jordan Peterson is going to not
only come on the podcast but maybe do it
live in person either here in San Diego
at some point or in Toronto
and I know some of you guys don't like
him I just I know it it's definitely
true and and I don't agree with
everything he says as well
but the fact is he's a brilliant
individual he's a cultural phenomenon he
has great insights into other dimensions
of my personality including being a
father including being a man and being a
scientist and and trying to understand
essence of of nature and so forth but
also being interested in topics like
religion and think I'm not interested in
the culture War I'm not going to talk to
him about trans pronouns and coven 19.
that's no I don't care about that but I
do want to talk to brilliant individuals
and that will be you know a very very
cherished opportunity if I get it and it
looks likely I will need your help
because a lot of people subscribe I
talked to my friend Kurt Jam ungel
yesterday
um and he's been a great friend and I
was on his eight hour marathon on a New
Year's Eve Eve last week and we chat all
the time and he may be lurking here and
there and you know he kind of advised me
you know be careful not to lose
subscribers because it's much harder to
you know keep a subscriber and you know
get them back than it is to gain a
subscriber and uh an alien girl I agree
Kurt rolls he's kind of been an
inspiration to me but I took slight
disagreement I said look you know if you
just do what your audience wants then
you might not really be in this for the
right reason and I'm not accusing him of
that I'm just saying you might be
captured by their intentions and that
may not take the channel where you need
to go I mean look if I want to monetize
this channel uh and really just just amp
it up and get you know quit my professor
job and do all this stuff I mean we
could do it Kurt does do YouTube 100
full time and he's excellent at it and I
respect him tremendously because he's
doing the real thing I am blessed that I
don't have to do only YouTube I have my
books I have my podcast I have my um my
University professorship and I get to
interact with the most brilliant people
on Earth such that if YouTube decides
tomorrow to cancel my channel
you know Life Will Go On I'll have other
opportunities most of all being a
scientist working on cutting edge
research at the literal top of the
planet in Chile at uh 17 200 feet
assignments Observatory which is my
lifelong dream so on the other hand I
don't want to be captured but I also
want to have good conversations and I
want to grow the channel so anyway if
you can help out and by the way Kurt was
on Jordan Peterson's channel so it's
even more than you know than maybe I'm
doing uh so you know if if Jordan's good
enough for Kurt he's certainly good
enough for me anyway let's move on to
the story shall we and uh so I'm not
going to talk too much about the the
items that I mentioned except number
four on my list that got 33 uh percent
vote was the fact that NASA has
commissioned a panel for studying
unidentified aerial phenomena and that
is I think a very very important story
because it really represents the first
time that uh we were able to get buy-in
you know at the federal level
from you know the highest or most
respected agency which is NASA I mean
that that's just a fact that studies
space I mean space force is coming on
strong but it's still
it's still uh you know kind of in a
nascent phase and it has a different
mandate than NASA
um so a lot of what we'll talk about
today have to do with NASA's discoveries
of starting with uh the very first thing
that happened you know in the early
parts of 2022 which was the arrival of
this object in real form
uh so one of the cool things about being
a professor at the greatest University
in the world is that I have the greatest
students in the world and they make me
all sorts of presents so this is
um available I should give this to to T
Carr at some point if he comes and
visits so maybe I'll give this to him uh
and in gratitude that's real gold that's
solid gold plated uh hexagonal mirrors
so in the real jwst is six meters across
this was 3D printed by two of my
students and lovingly assembled it's
real mylar down there how cool is this I
mean I got these awesome students and
they're going to go out into the world
and be even better scientists than I am
um if all goes as planned so jwst
gotta be tops of stories at least in
astronomy and some of the discoveries
that it made were just absolutely
breathtaking from a visual perspective
but we astronomers
since the time of this guy Galileo
have been looking up at the heavens with
telescope and making hypotheses modeling
what is going on in the heavens above
and by doing so we are able to really
instantiate for the first time the
scientific method how can we form a
hypothesis use observations refine the
hypotheses discard inconsistent
phenomena and come to a closer
approximation to truth and that reminds
me there's a great YouTube channel
called Closer to truth I'm going to be
on that channel uh which is coming out
it'll be also on television
I did some amazing video footage with um
with my my good friends uh who run that
channel Robert Kuhn uh they've got half
a million a million more people and look
for our collab with them coming soon
along with my friend Arvin Ash who's
agreed to do a collab with me about uh
the physics of time that's coming soon
so uh I think you're in for a really
phenomenal 2023 but in 2022 this object
JW's team made it to L2 this uh very
special Point called LaGrange Point
number two that orbits in a not
stationary position but it does Orbit in
a stable orbit a million miles from
Earth four times the distance to the
Moon and took these phenomenal images
um I suppose if I was a better YouTuber
I could fold in some of the pictures let
me I'll try to put up some here
um as we're speaking here so just
beautiful images here the Karina nebula
let's see if I can get that going on the
screen here we go bam covers up me
and that's okay beautiful and then we
had of course The Pillars of Creation
let's do that one here we go
this one gets
gets a special special place
in the Stream bam let's see if that
comes up look at that that's amazing
that's beautiful now as beautiful as
these are that's incredibly important
and of course things like the Hubble
Deep Field were incredibly important
last year
and in years past but what do we get
scientifically that we didn't know
before uh we got a lot this year from
jwst including the initiation of a great
controversy no I'm not talking about the
fact that James Webb himself was really
um exonerated from charges of homophobia
that came out from past guest hakima
lashayi you can find that episode and I
reposted it also in audio form and there
was a New York Times article on the
front page of the New York Times Really
clearing not only James Webb's name but
hakeem's as well because he had come
under kind of a very serious and vicious
and unjustified attack in my opinion
that sought to destroy his reputation
and a lot of that has been undone
thankfully and it was great to see that
in the New York Times and sort of a
paper of record to get the attention
that Hakeem deserves and to really clear
the name and also Barbara Webb who may
be out there uh James Webb's daughter
watching She's uh subscribed to my uh
Twitter feed as you guys all should Dr
Brian Keating
uh as well as the YouTube channel so it
was really great to kind of do a do a
kind of Rehabilitation not that he
needed my help James Webb I mean it's
phenomenal contributions to humanity
through not the least of which the
Hubble sorry the Apollo program in the
very extremely early portion of the
Hubble Space Telescope with with Spitzer
I wasn't really calling that back then
uh Lyman Spitzer at Princeton but uh
these are some of the great triumphs of
of 2022 and I'm told that that uh
interview that I did with Hakeem our
keem's presentation played a not
insignificant role in the publication of
the story that did emerge in the New
York Times and so that's gratifying that
I could play a role and and so forth we
also had news about exoplanets from the
jwst here's a image here that's way too
small
blow it up where we actually look at
data and we see the presence of things
of complex molecules carbon dioxide and
other things in the atmosphere of an
exoplanet not just seeing that they
exist which led to the Nobel Prize in
2019
but uh but the fact that they have
complex chemistry in their atmosphere
some say if you see things like carbon
dioxide that's a harbinger of life so
it's not necessarily proof that life
exists it may not even be evidence of
the possibility of life in other words
it might not only be a neces it might
not not only be not sufficient the so
many knots here not theory is my is my
hobby but there it also may not even be
necessary for Life As We Knew from the
phosphine claim that phosphine is a
biomarker that has nothing to do with
carbon dioxide so that being ruled out
does that you know enhance or constrict
the possibilities of life I don't know
um but certainly you know we didn't spot
you know space Disneyland on wasp 39
Bravo but it's an important proving you
know stepping stone props towards
confirming the existence of life on
other planets or maybe ruling it out and
uh and it's fascinating to think about
what Webb will do in the next year
of course there was a
um there was controversy regarding the
uh the existence of the Big Bang itself
claimed by an individual by the name of
Eric Lerner who may be out there as well
um and we did I did two videos about uh
the existence or not of evidence for or
against the web telescopes
um images of Galactic structures and
whether or not those Galactic structures
provide any evidence for or against the
big Bang's existence and I did one solo
and I also did one along with
um my friend and colleague Aaron Lewis
professor in Australia
and that was really quite delightful to
go into a deep dive and avoid so-called
uh you know paradoxes where we enter
into potentially ad hominem attacks that
Lerner had accused us of
um but but in reality I think it's
important to note that there are there
are flaws there are problems with the
big bang There are problems with what's
called Lambda CDM con uh the the kind of
concordance model that we call it but
the universe is dominated by matter of
an unknown character called dark matter
we had plenty of videos about that this
year uh and also it's uh energetic
energy budget is dominated by something
called dark energy which we know even
less about and we can't even access and
get good limits on experimentally uh in
the laboratory the way that we're doing
stuff even here at UC San Diego with my
colleague
past guest and Elena April of the Xenon
one ton experiment phenomenal World
beating limits on the amount of
particulate dark matter
so we entered into some discussions of
mod alternatives to dark matter in
particle form what if we can modify the
laws of Relativity but even before we
modify relativity we can modify
Newtonian Dynamics what would that say
for the not only presence or absence of
the type of dark matter that most
scientists do believe exist
but more than that we would have some
inkling as to where you know the
universe could be headed in terms of its
future Evolution on Galactic and
subgalactic scales so we did uh some
some deep Dives there and talked about
galaxies that don't have dark matter we
talked about galaxies that are only made
of Dark Matter uh or at least seem to be
dominated by dark matter
and I think uh it's really fascinating
to know that that's the way good science
works it's not as
you know my friend Eric learned I
shouldn't say my friend that's usually
it cannotes a put down let me say Mr
learner uh it's not a sign of unhealthy
bias sensorious scientific
uh process because you can't get your
paper published uh in fact it might be
seen by somebody who is truly pursuing
knowledge that it may be that it's much
harder I've had very few papers accepted
in my life on the first try I published
200 and something papers
um they've been cited
13 000 times Maybe
and not one of the 200 papers well one
of them was one of them was just
accepted as is and that was extremely
gratifying uh paper I wrote 10 years ago
uh last month
about calibrating Cosmic microwave
background polarization experiments like
the kind that we work on with the Simons
Observatory
so these are uh these are things that we
want to uh have in place that will
perhaps point us to new physics and the
the fact that some will claim that the
inability for
observations Say by web to be
incorporated with the current prevailing
Paradigm that's not a crisis you don't
just say oh all physics is moot I guess
I picked the wrong profession I should
become a YouTube streamer full-time and
obviously I don't have the talent for
that but the point being we can't look
at the gaps of flaws in current
observational connections to our
prevailing hypothesis and throw it all
out a good scientist there's an article
by James Peebles renowned scientist the
grandfather of modern cosmology involved
in everything from
the discovery of the cosmic microwave
background in 1965 he missed out and was
scooped famously to our understanding
our first understanding of how dark
matter really
is inescapable given the distribution of
what are called CMB anisotropies in the
1980s I had a nice conversation with
Professor Dan Green about that today in
person in a studio about 10 feet over
that way and look for that Dan's you
know another thing I want to do this
year is not have like oh I have to get
on every Nobel Prize winner in the world
but just the most brilliant people some
of which happen to live here in San
Diego and I happened to uh you know have
the same person signing the fronts of
each of our paychecks you know these are
phenomenal professors that I'm blessed
to have and that's actually how the
podcast got started if you don't know I
mean I am affiliated with What's called
the Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination which has been around for
about 11 years and uh in 2020 when the
pandemic hit I realized that all these
brilliant speakers like Freeman Dyson
and and others would not be able to come
through San Diego anymore and so I want
to start to do remote interviews with
them
and uh record those remote interviews
before that I had had Freeman on the
podcast in fact he was my first guest on
the podcast
in 2017 it was Audio Only and I realized
well we're not gonna be able to get them
back uh and sadly he passed away shortly
after the pandemic uh kicked off but uh
nevertheless we had all these brilliant
people coming through for the Arthur C
Clarke Center and I was kind of in this
position I wanted to give back not only
to the 190 people that would come to a
lecture by these great intellects and
then I'd get to moderate but to
everybody out there in the world uh and
we've been able to do that through this
YouTube channel
so I'm very grateful for that uh so
let's get back to some of the the
greatest hits
um of the past of the past year so
certainly uh the astronomy was really
dominated by Webb uh the the fact that
it not only worked almost flawlessly it
was hit by a meteor but besides that it
kept kept spinning and was able to take
images of everything from
from uh these distant galaxies the
pillar of creation to things in our own
solar system like this object here
Neptune oh no that's Jupiter uh but then
next to it as a moon of Jupiter and uh
and it's pretty phenomenal they also saw
incredible images from Neptune and its
Moon Titan just just phenomenal and
imaging it uh is really just spectacular
I also had a return to the Moon which uh
you know it's kind of interesting we
haven't been to the Moon in 50 years
and I like to point out it's longer that
we haven't gone to the Moon
then the time period between the
discovery and the the the uh the you
know kind of first explorers to reach
the South Pole in 1911 1912.
took 45 years for people to get back to
the South Pole it's taken longer to get
back to the moon and the moon has just
as many
possibilities not only for scientific
exploration as I use it for bicep
Ice Cube uses it for Ice Cube you can
see it over my uh shoulder on this side
there's a picture of bicep at the South
Pole this one is of the polar bear
telescope in Chile where I just was last
month
uh so it's really phenomenal I hope we
will get back there
um I'm looking forward to Jessica Maier
who is past guest two-time guest on the
podcast I interviewed her once while she
was on the space station talk about the
Sea of Neil Tyson can do that I mean
come on Neil gotta up your game my
friend
had her on and uh while she was on the
space station and then I had her on
again and she may be the first
she may be the next person on the moon
but she if she is she'd be the first
woman to ever go to the moon and I would
just love that because she's an
incredible human being she spoke in our
commencement this past year uh and I
just had a wonderful time hanging out
with her uh some of you mentioned this
experiment here leave a comment if you
know what that is this is a picture of
an asteroid which we slammed into
unceremoniously I wrote about that in my
most recent uh Monday magic email
message list where I share a a meme no I
don't share her meme I share a memory an
appearance something that's genius
something that is a beautiful image and
then a conversation AKA a podcast so
subscribe to the mailing list and you'll
get those uh about every two weeks I
don't like the spam takes a lot of time
I like to put a lot of effort into it so
Dart slammed into this double asteroid
redirection uh test and it slammed into
a moon of an asteroid it's insane uh
dimorphous the moon of asteroid 85 803
didmias
in a test of planet
that's incredibly cool because you know
if you watch what Deep Impact with Bruce
willisty freaking nuked that thing and
uh that's not the best idea or don't
look up uh the great uh great kind of uh
cautionary Tale movie that came out last
year which I liked it's depressing but
it's kind of funny as well
we also had on uh Shep todelson
uh and he dolman rather and he explained
this image here what is this image of
everybody out there it is the monster
black hole at the center of our galaxy
here it's over my monster Miss mouth
and that's our Galaxy's black holes it's
a follow-up to their Smash Hit from two
or three years ago where they imaged m87
perhaps the most energetic of all
objects this one's really phenomenal
because we can start to do
multi-messenger astronomy where we can
compare the image made by this vast
planetary sized Event Horizon telescope
which is a worldwide array of millimeter
and microwave and radio wave
astronomical telescopes from Chile to
the South Pole
in Europe and Africa and we can take
these images and compare with the
results of my colleague up north at UCLA
Dr Andrea Gans and past guest Reinhardt
genzel
um I'm trying to get Andrea on all the
time so far no good but we'll hope to
have her on so now we can compare
Optical and infrared Imaging direct
Imaging with the Event Horizon which you
can't see using optical or infrared
Imaging that Andrea and Reinhardt do in
their groups you can bind that and you
can start to test deep aspects of
general relativity and extreme gravity
we can never do that before and you
can't do that with m87 so this was more
important as it was actually a bigger
challenge because our Milky Ways uh
black hole is is thousands of times less
massive than m87 but it's you know kind
of the most important thing as any real
estate agent will tell you is location
location
so we want to make sure that we have a
actual understanding of this enormous
monster Behemoth in our own Celestial
neighborhood
that was another incredible Discovery uh
we had
um
uh several other kind of Runners up as I
said the the phosphine discovery was
ruled out by this instrument here which
you know I'm a pilot I like to fly
little Cessnas around my dream was to
fly on this as an astronomer pilot and
Captain the 747 known as Sophia
unfortunately it's shut down it's
probably out in the Boneyard it has a I
think an 80 inch telescope on it and uh
I'll never get to do it so I snoozed and
I lose so I won't be able to participate
in this incredible uh stratospheric
Observatory for infrared astronomy but
they did manage to make this
disconfirmation of this previously
incredibly hyped up including by people
like me uh discovery of phosphine
allegedly on the planet Venus's
atmosphere
so a swan song Final flight for the
Sophia instrument
uh we had a couple other pieces of news
uh that were kind of null results the
dark matter you know has yet to be
discovered by the liquid noble gas
experiments
um we also had uh and got inkling that
we're not going to rebuild the Arecibo
telescope sadly and we've had uh shows
about many many of these things here
so um let's turn to physics now so that
was just pure astronomy there are a
couple of great physics
um uh announcements so there was of
course the announcement of nuclear
fusion being achieved on Earth in a
controlled fashion we had achieved many
many hundreds of times have we had
nuclear fusion take place on Earth
unfortunately those were an atomic blast
and those require nuclear fission
devices to initiate to trigger but this
one had a trigger using late 192
high-powered lasers that blasted into a
deuterium tritium Diamond sized pellet
igniting it and causing it to give off
two Mega joules of energy I think it was
with only
um one less than one megajoule of of
energy input in the sense of the the um
the blast that triggers it
from these lasers uh and this takes
place over a trillionth of a second or
so uh unfortunately it's completely and
utterly impossible to use this
technology to actually or to use this
fundamental physics breakthrough to
actually accomplish a
um working electronic you know power
generation system but nevertheless it
was an incredible uh breakthrough in
many ways and uh and I think they you
know kind of
um Hope Springs Eternal and I think this
will take a lot of
um of our attention towards maybe
commercializing this and just as
commercial uh pressures have been great
for
NASA in terms of really getting us to
the Moon again really probably wouldn't
have happened without Elon Musk and
SpaceX kind of really pushing them to uh
to up their game and uh in the private
space sector and I'm hoping this will
happen you know kind of in Reverse where
government will then you know provide
impetus for private companies to then
make Leaps and Bounds in their
um in their Fusion game
so other things that that took place
that really fascinated me this past year
had to do with fundamental particle
physics including the announcement of
the so-called discovery of a pentaquark
so pentaquark is is not five quarks
necessarily uh it's uh sort of a
description that uh this you know type
of particle could include a
um a particle with five quarks instead
of the typical three or two and and even
what they called a tetrachark which was
a combination of two two Quark atoms and
then synthesized into or in like pions
which are Quark anti-clark Pairs and
this you know combined was really it was
sort of expected that you could have
behavior of hadrons in this in this
format and it became kind of interesting
to me if you look at it it kind of looks
like a chemical bond like it looks like
they're forming you know within this
five Quark system which is made up of
the letters here s the strange C is
charm up is up quark and then down D is
down that they're it's almost like a
molecule
um and then but there's no electrons
here so it's it's very different it's
it's sort of molecular uh uh appearing
but it's these aren't actually molecules
these are uh hadrons and um combining
together with things like pions in uh in
this very interesting and and unexpected
way I thought that was a really cool
discovery that uh colleagues at LHC had
made
and uh we also had of course the
announcement every October is Christmas
for nerds and we have the announcement
of the Nobel Prize in physics
and that went to people that were
entirely expected to win for a long time
including uh the man on the right uh
shown here Anton's Islander who is a
second
cousin I don't know he he and I are
related in some way uh you know the guy
with the glasses here uh in that they uh
he worked very closely with my good
friend and late colleague Andrew
Friedman who passed away two years ago
sadly
and uh and Andrew had worked on uh this
confirmation of the local realistic
description of quantum mechanics using
photons as
um as sort of triggers from distant
quasars and so in other words they were
able to understand the properties of
so-called spooky action in a distance uh
and that was maintained and kind of you
know ratification of the more or less
how the standard interpretation of
quantum mechanics that Einstein did not
like
and verifying that actually did take
place uh and it takes place not only on
Earth and in short separations but takes
place over the vast volume of our entire
solar uh Universe uh and so Andy had a
had a great role in that and um and was
some of the work was tangentially cited
by
uh by the Nobel committee I just wish
Andy could have been alive to witness it
so uh so those are some of the top 10
hits there was uh discoveries uh from
the lhcb experiment which
um had been announced to Great Fanfare
last last year two years ago and
discovery of this called bottom of
beauty quarks they had observed these
rare phenomena and
um and then there was basically
uh a a claim that no we don't we don't
have new physics Discovery
um and that there is
um you know kind of less room in some
sense uh for modifications to the
standard model of quantum mechanics
and that was uh you know that was sort
of uh upsetting in some ways to many
people again part of the academic you
know hype cycle or whatever
um that we'll talk about when I release
in this video that I'm tentatively
thinking of calling the academic media
hype complex so that was um you know
kind of a disappointment as I said there
have been you know many many discoveries
but oftentimes there are discoveries
that don't pan out and there may have
been other phenomena like that
where you've witnessed these huge
announcements but then the breakthroughs
don't hold up and that's a tribute and a
testimony to the self-correcting nature
of science so I'll be talking about that
when I release this video academic media
hype cycle I'll even talk about my
experiences with it uh tangentially in
the phosphine announcement from three
years ago now and in the disconfirmation
of that but also in the bicep 2 Affair
that led to the great Revelation that we
don't yet have information that proves
or excludes inflationary cosmological
primordial perturbation formation in the
early universe
so uh it was an exciting year a year to
beat hopefully we'll have a great guest
coming up uh again my good friend Eric
Weinstein has committed to coming down
and doing an episode in person
at some point I'll look for that and
look forward to an in-person interviews
Galore including uh one that I just
recorded this morning with Professor Dan
Green of UC San Diego
follow him at Nu underscore phases on
Twitter and he had an epic tweet storm
in December tweeting out the last 40
Years of theoretical and experimental
physics discoveries that did not win
Nobel prizes but perhaps will in the
future so look for that in person live
interview with Daniel uh in just a few
weeks Professor or Dr Oliver philcox not
a professor yet but he surely will be
and his announcement of a very very
tantalizing hint of parody violation
normally associated with activities of
particle accelerators on Earth
discovered by Madame uh Wu C.S Wu I have
a video about that them the Nobel Prize
that wasn't something like that
and uh but we've never really observed
it in cosmological scenarios which in
Oliver's words as you'll hear
could imply that gravity doesn't obey
parody symmetry so parity symmetry is
that if you reflect something in a
mirror uh it really is independently
behaving uh than If You observe it
directly so if you look at the solar
system in a mirror and then you look at
it upside down
you can actually not tell which uh
Direction you're looking at it or if you
look at some simulation of cosmic
structure or the actual Cosmic
structures themselves and I tell you oh
you looked at in a mirror you just
didn't know it there's no way you can
tell but when you have more than a more
statistical power as Oliver and his team
do you can actually reveal the presence
of very very subtle parody violating
effects which would have stunning
implication I agree with Mark
kaminkowski that if this is confirmed it
will be Nobel Worthy
uh so look forward to those interviews
and we have more Phil plate the bad
astronomer is coming on for his new book
I've got it in the other room over there
um Dr Susie Sheehy wrote a book the
matter of everything is coming on in a
couple weeks and uh that's a phenomenal
book and we'll be doing as I say a lot
more in-person high quality 4K videos
and uh it will be a year to beat and
hopefully we'll crack that magical
mysterious mystifying hundred thousand
follower threshold and then then I'll
retire no I'm not gonna return I'm gonna
keep doing it keep providing you free
content greatest and best intellects
some videos from yours truly as well
so do leave a comment thumbs up I hate
asking you people tell me to stop doing
it but
the fact is it's just the rules of the
algorithm especially when you have
people that are causing you to get
suppressed uh which is happening the
more controversial guests that I have
like Dr Jay bhattacharya and even Dr
Charles Seifer Mr Charles seif he's not
a doctor but he's a professor at NYU and
that gets slapped and demonetized and so
forth so do me a favor and uh spread the
channel and sign up for the mailing list
do it now oh I should say if you have a
edu email address and you live in the US
I will guarantee send you one of these
meteorites one of these bad boys
so this is a highly magnetized fragment
of our solar system and its formation
4.3 billion years ago I'll send you some
information about observing those
meteoroids and meteorites and you can uh
get that uh chance at brownking.com list
but like I say if you have a edu email
list that's my target audience
undergraduates graduate students
post-docs professors we have thousands
of people 10 000 people and I just love
it so please do sign up for that
we'll do spread the channel share the
love thank you guys so much for a
wonderful 2022 80 000 subscribers up
from zero two years three years ago now
uh and uh it's just incredibly
mind-blowing that you guys are along for
this ride into the brain into the cosmos
and Beyond
with yours truly Brian Keating
Chancellor is a singers professor of
physics
associate director of the Arthur C
Clarke Center for human imagination
signing off wishing you all a wonderful
weekend thanking you so much for joining
me on this wonderful ride into the
cosmos be well everybody thank you all
so much